[Music]
Travis Scott and Kylie Jenner have kept
a low profile since the birth of their
daughter stormy on February 1st but that
may be changing soon on Thursday the
rapper posted this pic of the couple to
snapchat it's the first pic of the two
together since their little one was born
the 20 year old reality star purposely
stepped back from public life during her
pregnancy but a source told ET in
January that she would return to the
spotlight after giving birth and now it
appears she's easing back in on Sunday
Kylie was snapped out and about in LA
hitting up Starbucks with her bestie
Jordan woods before heading to a
friend's baby shower the beauty mogul
shared the first photos of herself on
Instagram since giving birth Tuesday
posing in her Bentley while wearing a
burgundy Adidas tracksuit and the next
day Kylie posted this Valentine's Day
mere selfie so far this is the only
photo the new mama has shared of stormy
and it quickly became the most liked
post on Instagram
you